the country returns to normal millions
of americans are making summer travel
plans and
some major airlines are struggling to
keep up with
the demand american airlines has
announced it will cancel
nearly 1 000 flights through mid-july
because of a series
of problems including pilot shortages
chris van cleave is at reagan national
airport outside of washington chris
why is this happening
good morning people at american tell me
they thought they had built enough of a
cushion
into their schedule and they just didn't
demand came back faster than airlines
expected people
flooded into airports just as you saw
tough weather conditions computer issues
and
it's wreaked havoc for airline schedules
what that means for american
the airline is now cutting flights
it's been a june from hell for american
airlines it's operation seeing major
weather disruptions nine of the first
15 days in june causing long lines
delays and
cancellations leaving the country's
largest airline
with a staffing crunch along with
mounting flyer frustration
this was the only time we could get here
and i tried to check in
and they said now we have to wait until
about
three hours before the flight which is
at 4am 5am american will cancel 50 to 80
flights a day
through at least mid-july as the airline
tries to build in additional resilience
and certainty to its flight schedule
southwest has also been hit with delays
and cancellations due to weather
and a three-day series of computer
issues monday both airlines saw hundreds
of cancellations
and more than a thousand delays henry
hartebelt is an airline analyst
the airlines were caught with their
pants down they scheduled too many
flights
and they didn't have enough people ready
to operate the flights
operate the airports and the companies
that they work with
were short too as american ramped up
flights from 2200 a day to about 5 800
this month
the tsa struggled to have enough
screeners the airline's caterer in
dallas didn't have enough drivers
and some american pilots were still in
post furlough retraining
you didn't have enough piles to fly the
airplanes pretty simple
the metal and the people didn't come
together and now
you're surrendering the schedule
airlines are also dealing with an
alarming spike in disruptive passengers
prompting a rare industry-wide letter to
the attorney general
asking doj to send a strong and
consistent message through criminal
enforcement
we got to know that the federal
government has our back on this
now american has canceled more than 120
flights
today that's better than yesterday and
they did many of these in advance so
people don't show up at the airport and
find out their flights are canceled that
way they can re-accommodate them before
they
get here delta tells us that airline is
starting to hire a thousand new pilots
to have them in place by next summer
that first new hire pilot class will be
pilots who had been offered a job before
the pandemic
and that opportunity had been put on
hold tony all right if you ever dreamed
of being a pilot now's the time chris
thank you very much